with international master Lauren's Trent
the fourth best commentator in the world
except when he do a millionaire chess in
which case you jump back to the cutting
room falls is being very very nice
Maurice but thank you very muchly
laura's thank you for the introduction
gender during like good friends Lawrence
yeah so you are now a retired at chess
player we know those words you know the
word retired very rarely refers to chess
player since we can always unretire at
any moment but now you're the manager of
fabiano caruana it must be a real
interesting ride being a part of the
fobby team tell us what it's like now
instead of being a player being a
manager well firstly I just like to
clarify my retired state normally when
people retire they've actually achieved
something in chess I on the other
anti-aids it's a bit Greer's a bit grand
of me to say over tight now I'm just
taking you yeah I'm gonna love chess
forever but obviously I'm not level of
these guys so I didn't really make much
sense to continue in that sense ah so
what I've decided to do is well help
fabiano a bit off the board strictly
speaking and I want to make that
absolutely clear everybody who thinks oh
you know he's happening with his opening
preparation have you seen how I play
chess I don't want to jeopardize this
guy's career that much you know so I
stay as far away from the chessboard let
the pros do that and I take care of the
other things that he needs help with it
must be interesting though being that
close to greatness on a regular basis on
a daily basis this young man is just one
of the stars of chess a third highest
rated player overall time well I mean
it's very rare I you get the opportunity
to do this but also to be with somebody
I it's special for me because I'm a
chess player and you know you get people
who work in this kind of rollers manager
or agent they don't really understand
the sport or they've got you know what
they're not really linked to the sport
but I've been a chess player for all my
life so to be able to actually work with
someone who I truly believe has got the
goods to get right to the top obviously
this tournament hasn't started so well
yesterday was a very disappointing day
especially I don't think we can have
any complaints about round one but
yesterday against Magnus was
disappointing but I think it just goes
to show you know that he's very capable
of building manners showed showed it in
in Norway showed it on various other
occasions and with a bit more
development and bit more um bit more
sort of tweaking he's going to get that
I foot I truly believe that I really
believe you become world champion so so
what happens when he loses a bad game do
you take out the bait the baseball bat
or in your case the cricket bat yeah no
I've just got a very nicely sort of
developed whip that is it's not as hard
as a baseball bat but it's a bit harder
than slipper and we use that no I mean
look the good news is I know exactly how
it feels losing a chess game and it's
really as many people will attest it's
it's a horrible feeling and so you from
I can understand you know you have to be
able to balance it but also you have to
be able to be able to give constructive
criticism and be honest and I think
that's what Fabian who needs but he also
needs to know that he's darn good and
you know with as I say with a bit more
sort of tweaking of the machine he's
already a well-oiled Lamborghini he just
needs a bit more you know sometimes and
he's going to get there so yeah you have
to be reasonable and I'm not an
old-school Russian sort of mentor I'm
not getting out you know as you said the
baseball bat or you don't have him doing
pushups after the way we do have him
doing pushups actually that's exactly
what we do really well yesterday after
the game it was a very we used very
tense so I said let's just go down the
gym and you wouldn't believe fabiana is
an extremely strong young man he is
going they is lifting almost his body
weight he's nobody really sees it cuz
he's got the blazer on the shirt on but
I ripped he's in top shape and if I
usually write me down wait we should we
will think of I don't want to compete
with you it's you know have you seen
this guy with guys have you wanted I
mean it's outrageous you know he's
anyway um let's get back to the chest
yeah
and not the chest neurologist the
position on the board now he looks very
comfortable it looks like he surprised
nakamura in this opening looks like he's
got a good game well I think fabiana was
probably expecting this today I don't
know as I said I'm not involved in the
in the preparation side of things but
judging by the position right now he's
God enough pressure he's winning the
porn back on d5 he's got pressure on be
too I I don't see him having any
particular issues he's a bit down on the
clock but nothing dramatic either so
can't complain and I think it's not like
a commentator dude I should try it one
day uh I just think the important thing
today is that he gets off the mark as he
said I don't think he ever started a
tournament in his professional career
with two losses which I couldn't which I
found amazing but it may very well be
true says important just to get
something on the board and then you can
build from that tell me you're working
as a manager now there's some
opportunities you're finding for him
tell us a little bit about what you're
doing is chess players normally we don't
think of chess players getting
endorsements a sneaker contract right
all that what are you doing that is
changing the mold of how professional
chess is being viewed and in sponsorship
for chess place is being viewed today
well I think it's very clear to me that
this has been something that has been
largely untapped in the chest market and
I think it's been a of of the approach
and I think if you take a professional
approach opportunities will come so
we're delighted to to say that we're
partnering with the liberty science
center that's as well as the newest
chess club for the moment so that's
official and that's a very welcome
support and personally I'd like to thank
Paul Hoffman who's going to be coming is
a CEO of the liberty science center
based in New Jersey who who very much
believe in the same things we do there's
a great synergy between what they're
trying to promote and what fabiana
represents say is it just a perfect fit
for them and they're a perfect fit for
us and we'll be doing some great events
with them and I do believe that there
are opportunities out there but it's
about the approach and
about targeting the right people and
it's about doing things the way they
should be done I think that's something
that's lacked in the chess world
unfortunately and for us as well as
shown this I mean Magnus has got a
portfolio of sponsors of course he's the
world champion he's a darling of his
country annoy which is which helps but I
eat that that aside you can you can find
these opportunities you just got to do
it properly excellent no hope wish you
the best with that let me ask you one
question yes near and dear to my heart
yes we've talked about this how are you
going to be a commentator at millionaire
and be objective as you watch fabiano
also play The Millionaire chess open
that's tough it's got it just being a
manager is gonna be one thing how do you
fly into Lynn yeah that's that's
something I'm quite decided I'm going to
do I think I'm just gonna have to be
honest and professional if he's in a bad
position he's in the bad position and
I'm gonna have to say it how it is and
if he's winning i'll be shouting from
the rooftops you know and going crazy so
i'll be i'll be biased in that sense but
know what can I do hey it is what it is
I'll have to just control my emotions to
as much as I possibly can and if he's on
the verge of winning it then I'll be
getting my nice jacket ready for a night
out on the town because he's got a he's
got a great chance of winning it of
course but he carries their Wesley's
there amongst various others and two
games a day anything can happen so I'm
not getting my hopes up or anything like
that i'm looking forward to come and say
i'm looking forward to working with you
Maurice and the amazing tournament that
URL again for sure I can't wait to be
there and it's a sort of thing as well
that is very much part of the same
vision what you're doing what the guys
here are doing I mean the amazing
professional setup you have here it's my
first time here I just want to commend
everybody we didn't include by the way
we didn't do anything we just me just
show up it's spectrums no but I mean I'm
taking the time taken aback a big a big
thank you to everybody here the staff
and also to the sink fields who have a
pleasure of meeting and what they've
done to tutor I just couldn't believe it
when i walked in actually it's just a
it's i just feel like this is the way it
has to be it has to go this way the
journalism and if we can look at look to
this as a sort of benchmark then I think
there's a bright future for chess so
hopefully those words yeah well I
haven't even been paid to say that so
you know feel free to offer me a drink
later yeah guys dude you're gonna be I
want to say gonna be buying me yeah I'll
by buying it I just want to say a big
thank you as well to Yasser in Jen who
not just this event the past few events
just been fantastic in the front and new
Maurice and just the whole crew eschewed
smooth Brit all the tower you know what
can I say and look there's at least we
got that we got bad weather and you know
various other bad things but it's it's
great to be well international master
Lawrence Trey thank you always a
gentleman thank you so much I joining us
yeah he smooth smooth you know they
bring James Bond we got him right here